explosions at two of the bridges
connecting Russian annexed Crimea with
the other russian-held parts of Ukraine
the second attack on one of the bridges
in six weeks the local russian-backed
Governor says damage to the important
supply lines were caused by Ukraine's
nato-supplied Storm Shadow missiles
like this one President Vladimir
zielenski signing one of the storm
Shadows provided by France note the
Eiffel Tower on top of Ukraine's Trident
symbol
zelenski posthumously honoring an Air
Force member on the country's Air Force
day and praising service members for
their efforts
earlier this week he said training on
Western supplied F-16 fighter jets will
start this month
zelenski said this overnight airstrike
on a blood transfusion Center is a war
crime it killed two people on a night
when Ukraine says it shot down 57 of
Russia's 70 missile and drone attacks
the volley an apparent retaliation for
Ukraine striking against a Russian Navy
ship and a tanker in the Black Sea in
recent days Russia says it also
intercepted another drone aimed at
Moscow Sunday
and it accuses Ukraine of hitting a
university in Russian occupied Donetsk
with cluster bombs Global News cannot
verify those claims in Saudi Arabia on
the weekend the Ukraine peace conference
gathered 40 Nations together excluding
Russia but including the kremlin's
hugely influential Ally China so what
they're doing is they are trying to flip
more neutral countries and we saw China
participate which is a big deal the
Jetta meeting ended with participants
agreeing on more talks zelenski hopes
for a formal Summit later in the year
but it's going to take a lot of time and
I think the Ukrainian government is
doing you know hard diplomatic work and
bringing people
the territorial Integrity of Ukraine is
key to any peace plan and on that the
two sides remain as far apart as ever
Redmond Shannon Global News London